سباق مع الزمن دخلت به طواقم الاغاثه
والانقاء منذ ان ضرب الزلزال المدمر تركيا
وسوريا يتفق المسؤولون على ان الوقت ينفذ
منهم لاجلاء العالقين تحت الانقاض فما
المده التي يستطيع الانسان تحملها تحت
المباني المنهاره عاده ما توقف الامم
المتحده عمليات البحث والانقاذ عن عالقين
ومفقودين تحت الالقاد التي تخلفها الكوارث
الطبيعيه بعد خمسه الى سبعه ايام من وقوع
الكارثه لكن لا يمكن الحسم بشكل نهائي
بشان طول عمليات البحث والانقاذ ففي عدد
محدود من الحالات تمكنت طواقم الانقاذ من
اجلاء عالقين تحت الركام لا يزالون على
قيد الحياه بعد مرور حوالي اسبوعين ففي
بنغلاديش انتشرت امراه عام 2013 من تحت
انقاض مصنع بعد 17 يوما من انهياره وفي
2010 استطاع رجل الصمود والبقاء على قيد
الحياه لمده 12 يوما بعد زلزال هايتي
تعتمد مساله النجاه على ما يحدث لحظه وقوع
الزلزال فتوفر الاكسجين والمياه وعدم حدوث
اصابات جسديه امور حاسمه لصمود العالقين
لفتره اطول يبقى الانسان على قيد الحياه
بدون ماء لمده ثلاثه الى سبعه ايام يعتمد
ذلك على درجه الحراره وكميه السوائل التي
يفقدها الجسم بسبب التعرق والحاله الصحيه
والعمر ولان مساله الوقت حاسمه يعمل
العلماء على تطوير تقنيات عده للوصول الى
المحاصرين منها جهاز يدعى فايندر لا يزيد
حجمه على حجم حقيبه السفر الصغيره ويعمل
من خلال اطلاق موجات قصيره تحدد اماكن
المحتجزين على عمق 30 قدما من الحطام او
20 قدما من الصلبه كما يستطيع الجهاز
التمييز بين الانسان والحيوان عن طريق
معدلات نبضات قلوبهم وانماط التنفس
العلماء يعملون ايضا على تدريب بعض
الحيوانات الصغيره التي تستطيع الوصول الى
اضيق الاماكن تحت الركام وتزويدها
بمستشعرات واجهزه بث تشير الى المكان
الدقيق لوجود الضحيه وبصرف النظر عن حجم
جهود انقاذ الضحايا يبقى اصرار المحاصرين
الاحياء تحت الانقاض وعدم استسلامهم كلمه
السر للنجاه ونجاح مهمه فرق الاغاثه